In this video, we're going to look at Unreal Engine's modeling tools
and how we can use them to make some adjustment to the meshes in our project.
To start with, we'll look at the Xform tools,
specifically the pivot tool and the split tool.
There are many useful tools in this category,
such as deforming, sculpting, remeshing, and creating entirely new geometry.
So because we had some difficulties
when importing our FBX from Unity as separate meshes,
we are going to use the split tool before we use the pivot tool
in order to be able to better work with our individual pillars.
So in order to get to the modeling mode,
we'll come over here to Selection,
and instead we'll go here to Modeling or Shift 5.
Now, you'll see this opens a new UI panel for us,
our viewport is getting smaller,
and our outliner is getting kind of scrunched,
and it's a little in the way.
So this is where Unreal Engine's default layout starts
to make a little bit more sense.
And because of that, I'm actually going to bring the outliner
back over here onto the other side.
But I'll leave the detail side open for now.
So here we can see favorite tools,
we can create our meshes, select different ones,
select the faces of specific meshes and modify them.
But I'm going to come here to Xform and Split.
So as we can see now, it gives us a little preview
of the mesh that we have selected
and how it will be divided up into separate parts.
We can see that the bottom and each one of these pillars
is going to be put into a separate object.
So I will hit, we can change how we want to split it up
though over here, but I'm going to leave all of these
as default for now.
And thankfully it will transfer our materials as well.
I'll hit Accept.
And now we should see a new folder here called Generated.
And we see all of our new individual objects waiting for us.
We'll go ahead and save them all.
Fantastic.
And now we can see that we can click
on these, our individual pillars here.
The next thing we want to do though is Edit Pivot.
Before we'll go, we can see that our pivot point
is actually right here in the middle
where it shares that, the one that we had
with the bottom stage here.
So what we want to do is pick the first one,
go Edit Pivot, we'll hit Bottom.
Oh here it is, it was this one selected up here.
We'll hit Bottom, we'll hit Accept.
Fantastic.
We can go to the next one, Edit Pivot, Bottom, Accept.
We can also, if it makes sense for us,
we go to Edit Pivot, we can also rotate
the direction that the pivot is facing.
So if we want to have everything,
have its inherent rotations that they were exported with
now be baked into, or be visible in the outer transform
versus baked in, we can do that.
But for now, we'll just leave the transform
as the default rotation.
Oh, not split, excuse me, let's go back.
Here we go, Edit Pivot, Bottom, Accept.
And you can, if you can do this faster than me,
feel free to hop to it.
Oops, there we go.
Last one, awesome.
We'll make sure we save all of those.
However, we will notice though,
that now that these are all separate objects,
our BP session stage here still only has one,
our old static mesh is a part of it.
So in order to get these to be our new static meshes,
we're going to delete that,
come down here to our content drawer,
our generated, and we can select all of these,
drag them in, check out our viewport.
We'll hit compile, oop,
but now they're all sitting on top of each other,
so I might have hurt myself here.
I'll give myself a reference for how we can
bring them back and put them in their correct spots.
I guess one probably needs to go over here,
two will go over here, five,
go up top, see how we did here.
Try and get these close enough.
Thankfully, we won't need to rebuild any of our logic
because we're still just targeting our color MPC,
and we're not targeting individual material objects.
The next modeling mode feature we're going to take a look at
is the UV project tool.
There are a few different ways we can re-project
the UVs back onto our static meshes,
but in this case, we're going to use
the box projection method,
because that will give us a good look
that I want to have on our boxes.
We'll come here to our first cube,
we'll go to project UVs,
and here we can change from a plane projection
to a box projection,
and I also like to turn our box projection
so it's roughly facing the same orientation,
and that looks pretty good to me.
If we twist it around though,
we can see we get a little more control,
and so maybe we can have it to where it's scrolling up on the inside.
I think that'll look pretty good.
We'll hit accept.
Come to our next one.
Project UVs, that looks correct out of the gate.
Fantastic.
We'll come over here.
Project, accept.
Last one, accept.
And now we have them all flowing in the same direction
centered around the center of our stage.
In order to see our stage pillars changing color again,
now that we have modified their UVs,
we can delete all of these
and drag in our blueprint,
which now has the updated UVs for all of our assets.
Get ourselves a little bit centered.
Let's go back up and get it a little closer.
Now when we press play again, there we go.
In the next video, we'll start working with audio
and adding sound cues to our level.